you know this is a modern woman that
accepted what came with it she got a
house husband
now my thing is like if you're gonna
make a ton of money as a chick and and
be that boss CEO I don't know why you
would expect a guy to make more than you
you know what I mean it's like and on
one hand I'm gonna give her her prop she
did accept what came with it however she
said I would not be able to be the CEO
of the company unless I outsourced the
caring for my kids so we're getting to a
point where we are Outsourcing
motherhood and you know at the end of
the day kids don't need
money they don't need to be rich what
kids need is parents involved parents
and I do think it's more important that
the mother is home than the father is
home because the family unit in general
this is an exception will not survive if
the husband does not put his career
first